and and what what better day day than
today when uh you know we've already had
a tumultuous and volatile oil market and
what we saw in the last 24 hours beats
all of
that it sure does and really what we're
seeing is what I like to call A Whole
New World Order of global energy oil
producers and we're seeing that I mean
OPEC is really no longer effectively
operating as you know the cartel and
directing price so I mean last
yesterday's decision to you know hold
the line stay you know keep production
at 30 million barrels
is I can't say that it was unexpected
but really what it does is open up the
field for a whole new level of
competition and I I will you know like
everyone else will see prices I could
see prices going down into the you know
below south of $50 per barrel wow $50 a
barrel it was it'd be hard to imagine
just a year
ago yes um that here we are sitting
talking about crude oil prices you know
South of 50 I think is cons is you know
plausible you know keep in mind the last
time that OPEC did make a production cut
we have to think back to 2008 when we're
in the midst of the you know economic
crisis and prices dropped to $45 per
barrel so I mean there is precedent for
them cutting I think what you'll hear
though is that smaller countries within
the OPEC cartel begin to get louder and
louder and louder as their economies
really feel the pinch and you've
mentioned about a new level of
competition are you talking about OPEC
against us Shale oil
producers yes yes indeed so we have us
Shale producers you have Canadian Oil
sand producers I mean it's it's this is
now you know the OPEC faceof against
North American global oil producers and
it's all it's going to be about cost
structures and who has the lowest
marginal cost and you know it will vary
larger producers will remain in the
field smaller producers will go by the
way side but I I don't think it's going
to stop I don't think Shale production
is going to stop based on opec's even
though even though it's much more
expensive to do this
though I think for the larger producers
they have a different cost structure
than the smaller producers I mean this
is very analogous to what we're seeing
in the natural gas market today uh well
di on on that point you know we spoke
with John Hoffmeister who's the former
president of shell and he spoke uh quite
a bit about some of these oil producers
and and and how some are unprofitable
now at this 70 68 $70 level we are at I
want you to listen to what he said about
that sure we're going to see some
reductions in drilling rigs in the US no
question if the prices remain where they
are today that's going to immediately
affect the decline rate in the oil
fields and in the Shale formations where
you have decline rates in the in at 50%
per year you're going to see a lot of
oil come off the
market would you agree with that
we'll see that by the smaller producers
the smaller producers have very high
cost structures and I believe that they
will go by the wayside larger producers
you know the marathons Exxon mobils of
the world I can't see them I can't see
them slowing just yet uh you know OPEC
though though they decided not to cut
production hasn't made it any more clear
though what they're going to do next
right so again it's another kind of uh
waiting game here so the major oil
producers even though they might be okay
Guana here with with Shale oil
production aren't they still sort of in
a game of chicken here with OPEC and and
trying to figure out what they're going
to do and try to react beforehand and
and and game that out and that's going
to happen uh keep going for for the time
being yes yes it is I mean they're
they're going you know it's a question
of who can you know go lower how low can
you go and who can keep producing at the
lowest possible cost um so yes we all
have have to wait and see what happens
but I mean there is precedent for OPEC
you know cutting production levels you
know when they hit $45 per barrel in
2008 we'll see if prices go lower and
we'll we'll just have to wait and see
what happens